well it looks like we are going to be
seeing Venom versus Spider-Man a lot
sooner than we thought and I am talking
about Tom Holland Spider-Man versus Tom
Hardy's Venom now this was actually
teased in the post credit scene for
Venom 2 Let There Be Carnage and for the
post-credit scene of Spider-Man no way
home however it was kind of a teas of a
teas the post credit for Venom Let There
Be Carnage teased us that Tom Hardy was
now in the MCU however in the post
credit scene for Spider-Man no way home
they took him back to the Sony
Spider-Man universe only leaving a piece
of that Venom symbiote in the MCU which
is all Spider-Man would need to be
completely engulfed in venom and this
did set up a Spider-Man versus Venom or
at least Spider-Man having the Venom
symbiote suit in the next film however
as time went on we started to believe
that we weren't going to see the Venom
symbiote suit until Avengers Secret Wars
however a new report from a very
reliable ins Ider tells us that we are
going to see Tom Holland's Spider-Man
fight Venom sooner than we think the
only question right now is when when is
this going to happen is it going to
happen in venom 3 or is it going to
happen in Spider-Man 4 now of course
there is always the possibility that it
could happen in a movie like Deadpool 3
where we see a lot of different variants
in the same place however since this
Insider is stating that we'll see them
sooner than we think I'm assuming we'll
see Venom vers Spider-Man B for Avengers
Secret Wars in fact I think the story
could work very very well actually
leading up to Tom Holland getting the
Venom symbiote suit in secret Wars just
like he did in the comics and him
understanding what the Symbiote is and
intentionally using it to increase his
power we'll break it all down in this
video and if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest Spider-Man and Venom news
and of course MCU news as well and if
you subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series x a
PlayStation 5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month so The Insider can we
get some toast posed a question on
Twitter who did Venom better Insomniac
Spider-Man 2 for PS5 or Sony's Spiderman
Universe in which Insider my time to
shine hello responded with the movies
did it better they didn't even touch on
the split personality stuff in the game
movie Venom is also so much fun and I
can't wait to see him and Tom Holland
spider Man fight sooner than you think
now again this was teased by both Sony
and Marvel Studios in two different
films in a Sony Spider-Man universe film
and in an MCU film plus not to mention
Tom Hardy has been teasing a Venom
versus Spider-Man movie for a very long
time he specifically said in one
interview if they're in the Olympics
Spider-Man verse Venom is the gold medal
that's what they're shooting for and he
would be crazy not to go for that not to
go for gold this was him speaking after
Venom 2 talking about what Venom 3 could
have in store so we already know he said
that plus not to mention Tom Hardy is
pretty sneaky he constantly posts
pictures to his Instagram page and
deletes them right away and he's posted
pictures of Venom and Spider-Man a few
different times now again we now have
the Venom symbiote in the MCU but from
what we've heard it looks like it's
Marvel studios's plan to give Tom
Holland Spider-Man the Venom symbiote in
Avengers Secret Wars like they did in
the comics so if that is true how are
Venom and Spider-Man going to fight well
I think it will probably happen in venom
3 because they could set up the story in
the MCU not in the Sony spiderverse but
in the MCU in a really great way if Tom
Holland Spider-Man somehow goes to the
spiderverse and comes back one we know
that if it is a Venom versus Spider-Man
film Spider-Man and Venom aren't going
to be the end there is going to be
another villain in there we know how
these stories go it's kind of like a
Batman vers Superman and we know it's
not going to end with one of them dead
and there's going to be another villain
that they have to team up with each
other to defeat that'll most likely
happen in venom 3 if we do get a
Spider-Man vers Venom and that would
actually benefit Tom Holland Spider-Man
in the MCU at least at first so say
somehow and it's really not that
far-fetched to think about right now
since we are indeed in the Multiverse
Saga and we are going to start to see a
lot of different variants we're going to
visit other universes it's not too
far-fetched to think that Tom Holland
spider man somehow ends up in the Sony
spiderverse and somehow meets Eddie
Brock SL Venom well we know that Venom
kind of thinks that Tom Holland
Spider-Man looks tasty we saw that in
the post credit scene for Venom Let
There Be Carnage but we also know that
in the post credit scene for Spider-Man
no way home Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock was
stating to the bartender that he should
probably go go to New York and find this
Spider-Man guy then he seemingly got
brought back to his own Universe however
I will say that we don't exactly know
for sure what happened there but let's
say the opposite happens let's say Tom
Holland Spider-Man goes in the Sony
Spider-Man universe it's now possible
that Eddie Brock and Venom now know what
Spider-Man looked like because they saw
him on that TV screen so if he shows up
in their Universe they'll be able to
spot him and they'll probably track him
down if they see him this is how we
could get a Venom versus Spider-Man and
of course like I mentioned ultimately
they'll probably team up to fight some
other symbiote and of course ultimately
it would lead to Tom Holland going back
to the main MCU or perhaps maybe even
not if the TVA is showing up and
recruiting heroes in Deadpool 3 perhaps
the TVA shows up and takes Tom Holland
Spider-Man away to save him to bring him
to this battle World universe and
perhaps he even takes Tom Hardy's Eddie
Brock as well that way Venom and
Spider-Man are there we know Deadpool 3
goes right into Secret Wars and we know
that as of right now based off of what
we've heard it's Marvel studios's plan
to do a comic accurate Secret Wars for
Spider-Man where he gets the Venom
symbiote for the first time well if he's
on good terms with Venom and he sees
what Venom can do for Eddie Brock then
why wouldn't he think that a Venom
symbiote that could possibly be good
would be good for him and would give him
more power to fight Kang and all of his
variants it would be very clear to
Spider-Man that you could work with a
Venom symbiote together because that is
what Eddie and Venom are doing so it
would just make sense that he would
think well I already have my Spider-Man
Powers if I combined those with the
symbiot powers I would be even stronger
and of course I could help de beat king
this is how everything could be set up
but of course this is not the only
option we could go right into Spider-Man
4 and Spider-Man by the end of the movie
could have the Venom symbiote attached
to him somehow without him really
knowing that way when he goes into
Secret Wars that's when he really finds
out what it is now this doesn't really
give us our Venom versus Spider-Man
though again it is possible that that
could happen in Deadpool 3 Spider-Man
could get brought into that battle World
universe and so could Venom and Eddie
Brock because let's face it we know that
not everybody that's getting taken from
all of their respective universes are
going to be getting along on Battle
world if the TVA really is taking a
bunch of different Heroes and possibly
villains from a lot of different
universes and putting them all in one
place heads are going to clash even good
heads are going to clash it's not just
going to be heroes vers villains it'll
be heroes vers Heroes as well if you get
personalities like doctor strange and
Tony Stark variants clashing with each
other and perhaps maybe Victor Von Dooms
and Deadpool and Wolverine we know it's
not going to all be well
not all going to be good and we could
probably assume that some people are
going to die due to some fights so it
very well could be in Deadpool 3 that we
get a Spider-Man vers Venom but
unfortunately we're going to have to
wait to find out now of course it could
happen in Spider-Man 4 the Venom
symbiote is now in the MCU it is
possible it could attach to somebody
else however if they want to go comic
accurate it needs to attach to
Spider-Man first so it's possible that
it attaches to him then he gets rid of
it and then it goes to somebody else at
Eddie Brock of the MCU and they fight
that way but that goes directly against
the secret Wars plans for him getting
the Venom symbiote For the First Time In
Secret Wars unfortunately we're going to
have to wait to find out but let us know
what you think is the best option to get
a Venom vers Spider-Man in the MCU or
perhaps in the Venom Spider-Man universe
let us know all of your thoughts and
theories in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video And
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest MCU news of course you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof